Today,
I want to talk about options.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
wait,
wait.
I should just say what an option is.
Uh,
I'll write the word.
it's a contract that has an owner and the owner of the option contract has
rights defined in the contract,
uh,
either to buy or sell some thing,
let's say a share of stock at a specified price and specified date.
Okay.
So there's two kinds.
There's a put and a call.
Okay.
I'm a put option is the right to sell.
Uh,
it's typically a hundred shares,
so we'll say a hundred shares of a company and let's say it's Google.
Okay.
So,
uh,
the option would have,
um,
if it was a put option and there was a price,
then you would have the right up and,
well,
uh,
let me see.
There's the exercise price
also known as the strike,
uh,
and was the exercise
date.
Okay.
Um,
so,
um,
I should also emphasize that there are two kinds of op of options.
There are American,
so called,
uh,
and European,
so called,
it has nothing to do with whether they are in America or Europe because in
Europe they trade both American options and European options.
And in America they trade both American Hopkins and European options.
So it's very unfortunate terminology.
Uh,
the American,
what does this mean?
An American option means the right to exercise the option on any date until and
including the exercise date.
And with European it's only on exercise date.
So,
uh,
that's what those words mean.
So usually we're talking about American options.
Uh,
and so if have an American option,
um,
American put option on a shares of some stock,
uh,
then you have the right anytime you feel like it until the exercise date to sell
that option,
uh,
at the price specified in the contract called the exercise price.
Okay.
If it's European and you have to wait until the exercise date and then,
um,
then you have one day when you can do that.
A call option is the right to buy.
Okay.
Uh,
a share of stock or whatever it is,
whatever is specified in the option.
Uh,
and in a traditional option,
there's two,
there's two parties,
there's the buyer of the option
and usually we present them from the perspective of the buyer of the option.
A,
the buyer of the option pays a price to buy the option,
not to be confused with the exercise price.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
has,
depending on whether it's American or European,
has until the exercise date to,
uh,
to exercise the option.
But the buyer doesn't have to do anything.
You can just do nothing and we buy the option.
And if you do nothing,
uh,
it becomes worthless because the only way the option ever gives you value after
you buy it,
if you exercise it,
meaning you say,
I will use my right to two by herself,
the other party is the writer
of the option because it's a contract.
It has to be between two parties.
So if somebody is on the other side,
okay.
And you can do either one,
you can either buy or write an option.
Um,
okay.
So,
um,
if you it this clear,
uh,
if you write a call option,
then what you are committing yourself to do as the writer,
you sign the contract from the,
uh,
the writer's contract,
which goes along with the virus,
a contract which provides rights to the buyer.
If you write a call option,
then you and say it's American,
then you are signing a contract and let's say it's on stock to deliver 100
shares,
uh,
to the other guy,
the buyer.
Uh,
whenever that guy,
it feels like it and that guy will pay you the contracted price.
And so it's not,
it doesn't seem like much fun to be a writer of an option because you have,
you're just sitting there waiting for this other person to make up his or her
mind.
Uh,
but,
but there's,
there's a benefit,
namely you get the money that the buyer of the option pays you upfront for
providing this right to the buyer.
A and so writers have options,
uh,
right.
Them,
uh,
hoping that they expire on exercised and that's when they make money.
If you write an option and the buyer of the option,
Paisley of the money up front,
and then you never hear from the buyer again,
then you're in.
That's,
that's the way you'd like it.
And so you make money by writing options
and hoping that they don't get exercised.
Okay.
And of course you can write a put option a,
and that means if you write a put option,
you are signing a contract that says that whenever this other guy on the other
side,
the buyer decides to that guy,
we'll,
uh,
we'll sell you a 100 shares at the specified price.
Okay.
So,
um,
again,
you're laying yourself open to whenever this guy wants to,
uh,
you've got to receive a hundred chairs,
and uh,
uh,
and pay the money.
Okay.
Now,
um,
these kinds of contracts are very old.
Uh,
and in fact,
we had a conference over the weekend at the Yale School of Management,
uh,
on,
it was a very interesting comment.
I've never experienced anything quite like it.
Maybe I should put the website up for you to look at it.
Uh,
there's a book,
Oh,
it's called the great
mirror of folly
written in 1720,
uh,
about the stock market.
Uh,
and the Vikki rare book library has a copy of it.
they're very rare,
uh,
about the stock market crash of 1720.
Um,
did you know that there was a big stock market crash in the year 1720.
what was happening in new haven in 1720?
Well,
I know one thing that was happening in 1720,
you in new haven,
I'm guessing,
I'm pretty,
pretty sure you've had some pretty angry investors,
uh,
who lost everything in the stock market,
but it couldn't have been the US stock market,
which wasn't created yet.
Uh,
this,
the crash of 1720 was primarily in Paris and London
also last year.
So Amsterdam,
uh,
those were the financial centers of the world.
So I'm speculating.
There must've been someone here in new haven,
uh,
probably Yale University.
He lost in this crash.
I don't know.
Um,
it must have been someone here who lost,
it was a huge and devastating stock market.
And this is the first one,
actually,
the first stock market crash.
Uh,
and so we had a lot of fun at this conference and I'm,
it just relates to option,
I'll tell you why it relates to options because people were writing options
Galore in 1720 on stocks.
Uh,
so the,
the,
the book the great,
so he does it well if you search on Great Mirror of folly,
uh,
on the web,
it'll come up with our conference and proceeding.
And since this book,
uh,
you know,
copyrights expire after a,
what's a complicated formula,
but in less than a century.
So this is all public domain.
So yeah,
it has it up on the web and you can read the whole book.
Unfortunately it's written in Dutch,
but which might deter some of you,
but it has lots of pictures.
And we had great fun.
So at this conference,
um,
the,
uh,
it was the most interdisciplinary conference I've ever seen,
because we had professors from the art history,
comparative literature,
Finance,
economics,
psychology,
uh,
and we had scholars from all over the world who knew about the year 17,
20,
uh,
including a lot of Dutch,
a Dutch men who are here.
Uh,
because,
uh,
but anyway,
the highlight of it was a highlight for me was it had we saw a picture of an
option from this time,
uh,
an option contract to buy stocks,
from Amsterdam.
Uh,
and it showed,
it was a printed form.
They had printed forms back.
Now,
at least in Holland,
they did.
So offender had printed up with blanks to fill in as a place to fill in the
exercise price.
And the exercise date,
I don't know whether it was American or European at the time,
but I'm sure if it was American,
they didn't call it an American option in 1720.
They didn't even call them options because it's all in Dutch.
So I don't know.
Uh,
it was some other word,
not options.
Uh,
Brian just saying this because the,
the other interesting thing about 1720 is that,
uh,
they didn't make the same distinction between investing in gambling that we do
now.
So right now,
uh,
anyone on Wall Street is very low as to be,
have any suggestion of a connection with gambling.
Uh,
and so,
but back then they didn't care.
And so lots of socks would have lotteries attached or a,
there'd be all kinds of,
is something called a Tontine,
uh,
where a group of investors would invest in something and then all the money
would go to the last one to die.
Well,
after all of them died,
but one,
ah,
that's a sort of gambling.
I don't know what sense it makes,
but they did that.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I remember the old story and,
I,
I just heard this somewhere from the 1920s to brokers in the New York Stock
Exchange floor.
We're talking to each other and one of them says,
I'll bet you $5 that the market's gonna go up.
And then they senior man,
then Scott scolded him and said,
are you betting,
uh,
you know,
you will be thrown off this floor permanently if I hear that word again.
Um,
so that attitude has persisted.
That investing should be distinguished from gambling.
And I suppose there's good reason for that because gambling instincts can take
hold of us.
Uh,
and investing has a good purpose.
unfortunately our emotions can carry us away from the good purpose.
And gambling is not,
uh,
investing,
back in 1720,
the distinction was not so clear.
Uh,
and this event was so,
uh,
it got the reason they call it the book Great Mirror of folly is that the event
got totally crazy.
I mean,
people were squandering their life fortunes.
Uh,
well I'll tell you one more story.
We had a great time at this conference because this book mirror Fala includes
plays that were written in 1720 and performed in Amsterdam about the crash,
about the stock market crash.
So,
um,
uh,
the organizers of this conference got some students from Saybrook college to
perform.
One of the plays from Great Mirror falling.
Is anyone here from Saybrook?
Okay.
You weren't in the,
I didn't see you there though.
Um,
and so,
uh,
there was a scene in the play where a young woman is being told by her father
that he intends for her to marry a very promising young man who is speculating
and stocks and we'll soon be rich.
And he is very skeptical about being forced to marry.
Uh,
she has somebody else in mind.
and but the father says that other young man is worthless.
He'll never amount to anything,
but she stuck by her guns and insisted that I will never marry a man who is in
love with the stock market.
Um,
we don't know what happened cause it's all fictional.
But as we know,
the whole stock market crash that she was right and two counts probably
anywhere.
That's all about our options are very old.
Uh,
and uh,
but they've emerged more recently as very important,
um,
contracts and in particular,
what,
what they didn't have in 17,
23 if they didn't have anywhere until recently,
uh,
is uh,
an options exchange.
So,
uh,
the problem with a traditional option is that it's a contract between two
parties.
Okay?
Uh,
and if you write a few,
buy an option,
you're at the mercy of this other person.
So if you buy an option that was written by a broker as they were in 1720,
uh,
what if the other guy doesn't,
he just dips town,
he's gone.
You bought this option to either by herself and then when the date comes,
you can't find this guy.
So what do you do?
You obviously were cheated out of your money.
So,
uh,
we created,
that was a problem until 1973
when the first options exchanged open.
But I think there may have been ways of dealing with the problem,
uh,
but not,
before 73.
But,
uh,
this is the first,
options exchange,
Chicago board options exchange,
which was a spinoff of the Chicago Board of trade.
Uh,
and,
uh,
now what they did is they organized a central marketplace for a standardized
options.
Options used to be written for whatever exercise date anybody wanted,
Eh,
eh,
there was no,
there was no standardization.
It's like an options exchange is like creating a futures market when you only
had a forward market in the past.
So,
um,
they started trading options on us stocks in 1973 and they require that the
writer,
the writer of a naked call has to put up margin.
Okay,
what does a naked call,
if you write a call,
you are standing ready to sell a hundred shares to the buyer whenever that buyer
decides if it's American to do that.
But,
uh,
if you're naked,
if you don't own a hundred shares,
well one way you can do is you can,
uh,
you can show that you own a hundred shares a,
so there's no way that you could fail to deliver.
But,
uh,
if you're naked,
then you are required to put up margin and the margin is a,
an amount that was enough so that if you fail to deliver,
the CVOE could access your margin account and buy the shares on the market to
sell to the,
uh,
the buyer.
And there'd be enough money to do that.
Uh,
and so the margin requirement for the writer,
uh,
holds mix.
The contract is secure so that there is really no counterparty risk with
options,
uh,
purchased on an options exchange.
Now there's many options,
exchanges,
but the CVOE I'm just listing it was,
was the first,
uh,
so,
now our futures exchanges,
so options on futures,
uh,
that's the same thing as an option on a stock,
but instead of a stock contract,
it's a futures contract.
So,
uh,
and that would be done at,
at the CME group,
which is a futures exchange.
But that's,
uh,
that's just which,
just talking about where you can do these things.
Okay.
So I,
did I explain the concept of options?
Well,
let me,
maybe I should go through,
uh,
the,
where is my,
okay,
I have here a plot illustrating,
um,
a call option.
Okay.
Uh,
on,
on the vertical and the horizontal axis,
I have stock price.
There it is.
Okay.
That's $0 million a share,
$5 a share $10 this year.
And I'm showing it up to $45 a sheer.
Okay.
Uh,
now I'm going to illustrate the intrinsic value of a option with a $20 strike
price.
Now,
the option would be typically for a hundred shares,
but I'm going to describe it as if it were an option to buy one share.
Okay?
So that would be one 100th of a,
of a typical option.
Okay.
So this broken straight line is what we call the intrinsic value of the option,
which is the money you could get if you exercised it right now.
Okay?
If you,
if you decided it will never have intrinsic value negative because you wouldn't
exercise.
Uh,
so let me explain what this means.
Suppose you own an option with exercise price of $20.
All right?
And the price of a share is $15.
What is the value of that option today?
The intrinsic value?
Well,
it's nothing because the option gives me a right to buy a share at $20,
but hey,
I can buy it in the stock market for 15.
So I would never exercise the option today,
right?
Uh,
it would be worthless.
It would be,
it would be worth minus $5 if I exercise it today because I would be paying $20
for something I could get for $15,
but I'm not going to call it minus if I'm going to call it zero,
because he just,
you won't exercise it,
right?
So if the stock price is below the exercise part,
I have a value on the vertical axis is the intrinsic value of the call.
I have to distinguish it between actual value.
Uh,
uh,
this isn't the price that the mark that this is coded for the option.
This is what it would be worth if you exercise it today if it were,
uh,
but you know,
the option has value beyond its intrinsic value because even though it's
worthless today,
it might be worth something in the future.
And well,
I'll come back to that,
but this is just,
I'm just talking about intrinsic value right now.
One of the stock prices 30 today.
What is the value of the option?
The intrinsic value?
Well,
it's,
it's going to be 10 obviously,
right?
Because you,
if you exercise it today,
you're buying this stock for $20 and you can sell it today for $30 on the stock
market.
So the difference is $10.
So this line here,
it doesn't look like a 40.
This is a 45 degree angle here.
It doesn't look like it,
but that's what it is.
And it has a slope of one.
So that's how it's very simple.
The intrinsic value for it call is just a broken straight line.
It breaks at the exercise price.
Okay,
so,
um,
give me a little bit more jargon.
In this region we say the option is out of the money.
That means exercise today it would be worthless.
Uh,
and this one right here is called at the money.
If the stock price is equal to the exercise price,
then the stock,
we call the option at the money and for a call.
Uh,
and uh,
here,
if the stock price is above the exercise price,
we say it's in the money.
All right,
and this line goes off to infinity.
I just stopped it there.
Uh,
that's straight forward right there.
But anyway,
this does illustrate something about options that,
uh,
is different from anything we've discussed before.
This is a broken straight line,
not a straight line.
All of our talk about fort today has been linear.
When you combine stocks,
you are,
uh,
making your portfolio respond linearly to the return of any one of the stocks in
the portfolio.
But this is nonlinear cause we have a break and that's what options do.
Uh,
so,
uh,
there it's nonlinear finance.
Some people are confused about what options really are.
Uh,
often people say,
well,
if I buy a stock option,
that means I can make up my mind later whether I want to buy and sell.
And so,
uh,
Hey,
I'm just getting the right to be indecisive or did we think of it this way?
I haven't made up my mind whether I really want to invest in options or not.
So I'll buy it in stocks or not.
So I'll buy an option and that gives me the right to buy.
Well,
you know,
that you could say that a lot of people think that way.
Like a company will think.
We're trying to decide whether we want to,
uh,
build a shopping center.
So we'll buy an option on the land underlying where we would build the shopping
center.
And we'll think more about it and decide whether it's a good idea to build a
shopping center was that you could do that.
But this,
there's something a little bit misleading about that reasoning because whether
whether or not you decide to build the shopping center,
if you buy an option on the land,
you will always exercise it.
If it's in the money on the exercise date,
whether you build a shopping center or not,
right?
Suppose you,
you,
you couldn't decide whether to build a shopping center and you bought an option
on land.
And then someone comes in and says,
well,
we have to make up our mind today.
Uh,
the land,
the option is exercising is expiring.
If we don't exercise it today,
it's worthless.
So what do you discuss at your meeting?
You don't discuss whether we're going to build the shopping center or not.
That's irrelevant.
You discuss what can we sell the land for?
And if we can sell it for more than exercise price,
we will always exercise it,
right?
So there's no,
uh,
it's the assumption in finance is that all options that are in the money on the
exercise date are exercised and there's no choice.
The word option might be misleading because,
uh,
I mean you could choose to be dumb and not exercise it,
but that's not what it's about.
And the other hand options really are central to our,
our thinking about a lot of things.
I give you an example of an option that you might not consider an option a and
this is the option to marry somebody.
And so,
um,
sometimes people will complain that their boyfriend or girlfriend,
uh,
cannot commit.
Right?
We've been going out for three years.
It's time that we get married.
Uh,
but this person,
the other,
the counterparty cannot seem to decide,
but actually a one view of it,
of that situation.
It could be that this person has just better schooled in finance then the other,
um,
because one principle of finance is that you should never exercise in American
call early.
All right.
I'm not as cynical about relationship and I just telling you a story that comes
to mind.
Uh,
you'd never want to,
I'll come back to that.
You never want to exercise in American call early.
So that's why there isn't that important distinction between European and
American,
but just in the prince,
in the,
in the case of relationships,
uh,
suppose your a girlfriend or boyfriend really wants to marry you and uh,
it's still giving you time.
Then you instinctively know you should wait.
As I say,
not really,
but I'm saying in terms of theory,
you should wait until the last day when this other person says it's now or never
because there's always exercising.
There's always option value.
There's always a chance.
Um,
maybe that will come clear.
Uh,
I don't know if you'd like my analogy.
I'm not cynical about these things as some people are,
uh,
Peter,
this is a call option up here,
but this is a call.
I'm going to show you a pit,
but we'll go ahead.
What,
what are retired?
Wow.
Uh,
see the price.
I want to come back to the price of the option will always be above that line.
Uh,
so there's no Arbor we there are possible,
it depends on if the price is wrong,
they're arbitrage,
then he'd come back to that.
I mean,
uh,
this is a put option.
This is intrinsic value for a put option cause it's the opposite of a,
of a car.
Uh,
if the strike price is 20 and the stock price is selling for 15,
then uh,
you can see that it's in the money.
It's the right cause you can make $5 by exercising.
Uh,
you have,
uh,
you have the right to sell it for 20,
but you can buy it in the market for 15.
So you buy it from 15 and sell it for 20,
you make $5.
But on the other hand up here,
if they've stock prices $30,
you have the right to sell it for 20.
Well,
that's worth nothing,
right?
I can sell it for 30 in the market.
So,
uh,
but then what,
um,
uh,
let's see.
Do I have a,
let me,
let me jump to this.
This isn't exactly the order that I wanted to do it,
but,
uh,
the,
and this has to do with arbitrage as you were saying,
um,
the price in the market should always be greater than the intrinsic value until
the exercise date,
the last day for an American.
Why?
Even for American or European.
But let's,
let's talk American.
Uh,
this pink line is my price for the option.
And I will talk about how we get that line from theory.
But price,
if the,
let's say if it's an American option and it's got time to go,
let's say the exercise date is not for another year.
Okay.
Uh,
and it's out of the money.
The price of a share is only $15,
but the exercise price is $20.
That option is still worth something today,
right?
It's not worthless.
It would be worthless if you exercise it today,
but hey,
you're not going to exercise it today.
The reason it has value is that the price might rise above $20 sometime over the
next year.
And so it,
uh,
the,
you have a chance of making money in it.
So that means the price of the option is always going to be worth more than the
price
of the stock or it's always going to be worth more than intrinsic value.
What about Atha money?
And at the money option,
if the price of a share is 20,
and the option a and the exercises 20 exercise it today,
it's worthless,
but it has to be valuable because 50,
50 chance the stock price is going to go up.
Uh,
and so you have a good chance of making money on it.
So it's going to be worth,
it's going to be worth a lot more than than,
uh,
this one was down here because we're at the money,
you know,
any little jostle upward is going to put it in the money.
So there's a big chance that this will become in the money.
So it has real value.
Whereas down here,
the option doesn't have much value because it would take a big price move to put
it in the money.
And then what about up here,
even when they're in the money,
they're worth more than,
uh,
than intrinsic value.
And you kind of wonder,
well why would that be?
Uh,
well,
it's because this thing is better than owning the stock.
Say let's say at this point when the stock price is 25,
I'd rather own the option then their own,
uh,
share minus $20 because the option can't fail me as much as the share can.
This share minus $20 could be negative and value before the exercise date,
but the worst that can happen to my option as it would be worth nothing.
And so now the arbitrage of Peter that you were referring to is the arbitrage.
Uh,
what if the price were below this line?
Maybe that's what you were thinking of.
What are the option price,
but if the stock price is 30 and the option is selling at five,
if it's an American option,
I have an immediate arbitrage,
right?
I Buy,
what is it?
Uh,
I,
if it's a call option a,
I would buy the option for $5.
I would exercise it and sell for $30 and I'll make money instantly.
And so that can't happen.
We can't have the option price selling for less than intrinsic value.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the,
you know,
just from arbitraged at that pink line is always above the,
uh,
the solid line.
Moreover,
there's another,
uh,
arbitrage relation,
which I didn't really show on the chart,
but if we draw a 45 degree line here from the origin that's plotting the shock
price against the stock price,
all right?
It has a slope of one and it comes out of the origin.
No option can be worth,
can be priced up above that 45 degree line above here.
In other words,
an option can never sell for more than the stock.
Does that sound obvious?
Why would you pay a,
if the share is selling for $25,
why would I pay $30 for the right to buy it at $20?
Obviously,
it's ridiculous that the APP,
the sock itself is an option to buy the Sherif zero exercise price.
So it has to be worse to have a positive exercise price.
Okay.
So,
um,
now I wanted to stress the put call parity relation.
Uh,
and this is another arbitrage thing that um,
the put option price arbitrage,
the absence of arbitrage opportunities implies that the put option price minus
the call option price equals the present value of the strike price.
That's discounting it from this exercise date to the present plus the present
value or any dividends coming between today and the exercise date minus the
price of the stock.
And this has to hold because uh,
if it didn't hold there would be an arbitrage opportunity.
So,
uh,
the put,
let me,
let me just show you why this diagram was supposed to explain that.
I've got here the uh,
the intrinsic value of the car,
which is the yellow line.
And this is an intrinsic value of a put.
We've got them both at the same exercise price.
All right.
And then I've shown here the stock price when the Blue Line stock price against
stock prices,
just a 45 degree line,
a line with a slope of one.
Well you notice that if I were to buy a call and write a put that's the same
thing,
a shorting or put,
I would have a combined portfolio with just those two.
I would have,
uh,
the yellow line here and I'd have minus the pink line here,
right?
I would have a parallel straight line that looks just like the stock price just
shifted down.
So if I buy a call and short a put or write a put,
it's the same thing as owning the stock minus the exercise price.
And so,
uh,
that's,
that's what we have in the put call parity relation so that we're taking account
of a dividends.
That diagram didn't show the fact that stocks will pay,
might pay dividends between now and the exercise date.
Uh,
but you can see when I was just saying,
I've got,
I said call mine has put,
well this is put minus call,
uh,
minus the price of stuff.
I have a minus sign in front of everything here,
but it's just that,
what that diagram shows.
So what put call parity means is that we only need a theory of either call
prices or put prices,
and then the other one falls right out of put call parity.
Okay.
All I need is a theory of coal prices.
So we will just forget about puts and we'll just talk about calls from from now
on.
And then if I gave you a problem,
they ask you what is the put price,
whereas the price of a put,
you would go in and calculate the price of a call,
uh,
and then,
calculate,
uh,
we,
we the put option price,
we'll put this on the right hand side of the equation.
The put price would equal the call price plus the present value of the strike
place,
plus the present value of dividends minus the price of a stock.
So that,
so,
so that,
that makes it very easy.
All we have to do is worry about calls.
Um,
and so,
uh,
where am I?
Okay.
So,
uh,
the question for financial theory is what determines this pink line?
We,
you agreed that it should be above intrinsic value as,
as it,
the option gets closer to expiration as time moves on and the exercise date is
getting closer and closer in time,
this pink line is going to go down,
down,
and on the last day it hits the intrinsic value.
And so,
uh,
but what,
what is it before the exercise date?
So,
um,
I want to start with um,
uh,
a theory which illustrates how we calculate these things.
Uh,
but this is a theory that
applies to us too so that we can understand it easily.
It applies to a,
a strip down situation.
Well,
I'm going to derive the price of an option,
uh,
under the assumption that,
it's very simple.
There's only one period between now and exercise.
It's an,
it's a European option.
We're going to exercise it in one.
We have an exercise date of one period.
Uh,
and also under the restrictive assumption.
And this is for pedagogical purposes,
just to simplify option theory that the stock price s is the stock price today.
Okay.
And the stock.
This stock is very special because,
uh,
next period it can have only two values.
It's s times you if the stock goes up,
human stands for up and it's s times d if the stock price goes down.
Uh,
and what I'm saying,
what's arbitrary here is I'm saying that there's only two possible prices for
the stock next period.
Su or SD.
Uh,
that's not real world because as you know,
there's all kinds of infinite number of possible prices next period.
But again,
this is just,
I think that we should be able to figure out what the price of a call option on
this stock should be worth.
A,
it's very simple,
but it's,
I say it's very simple,
but the people who invented this won the Nobel prize for this.
So I won't,
I don't want to make it,
this wasn't so simple,
uh,
in the history of financial thinking.
But anyway,
so do you understand what the situation that we're proposing in,
it's just like there's this very funny stock that we know for some reason we
know that s is the price today and next period when the option exercise dated
it's price is either going to be su or it's going to bes s times you or it's
going to be as times d.
Okay.
And then there was an interest rate.
Then we can both borrow and lend at this riskless interest rate.
So what should the option would be worth a,
okay,
so in this case,
uh,
I'm going to call,
see the current price of the call today.
This is before now.
This is before,
uh,
the exercise date.
So the price of the call is going to be worth more than the intrinsic value.
Uh,
I am going to call c sub you the value of the call next period if the price is
up and see sub d the value of the call next period.
If the price is down.
Okay.
Uh,
that we,
that's the thing that we read off of those La broken straight lines.
Right?
So see you would be,
you know,
the stock price.
If it's the stock minus the exercise price,
if it's in the money,
we know that in advance because we already know what the two possible prices are
next period.
So we'd already know what the two possible option values are next period.
This is the intrinsic value up.
If it's up and this is the intrinsic value,
if it's down,
alright,
and we'll call it e the strike price of the African exercise price of the
option.
Is Everything clear here?
It's just such a very simple world.
I'm just saying
there's only two possibilities.
It's a,
it's a very simple world.
Uh,
and it's only one period between now and exercise.
So it's very simple.
Now what I'm going to say,
it's going to,
we're going to develop an arbitrage theory of options and we're going to say
that you want to,
uh,
you'll take any profit opportunity that's riskless and it ought to be possible
to get a riskless profit opportunity here,
uh,
by investing both in the stock and the option because there's only two possible
values for the stock.
And you've got both a stock and an option,
there must be a riskless portfolio,
right?
Because the price of the option depends only on the price of the stock,
uh,
on the exercise date.
And so when I'm going to do is get an optimal hedge ratio h uh,
that,
um,
that makes my portfolio,
I'm going to form a portfolio of the stock and the option and I'm going to put
them together so that I have a riskless portfolio.
All right?
And that's what I'm going to do out of that is going to fall a value for the
price of the option.
So this is what you want to do.
Okay?
Uh,
we're looking for a riskless profit opportunity.
Let's consider this.
We're going to write one call and buy h shares.
Okay?
And I'm going to pick h so that I have no risk at all and it's easy to see how
you do that because we already know before the exercise date,
we know that if the price goes up,
it will be worth you.
H S my portfolio,
if I have h shares,
the h shares will be worth Uhs,
right?
You is U s is the price h shares would be worth uhs.
Uh,
okay.
But I've written one call so,
uh,
this will be worth ewh as minus the price of a call.
Uh,
similarly,
if the price stock,
if the stock price goes down,
then this is the value intrinsic value of the car,
then,
uh,
next period and the exercise date,
the portfolio will be worth DHS minus c sub d.
All right,
so let's choose age so that the two are the same and all I have to do is set
this equal to this and solve for h and that gives me the optimal hedge ratio.
And so h is equal to c to view minus v Sub d Oliver,
you minus d times S.
Uh,
and now it's very simple to get to option pricing is that if I can form this
portfolio with a where I have,
um,
uh,
one call and h shares in the portfolio,
it's a riskless portfolio and so it has to earn the riskless rate of interest.
That's what no arbitrage assures.
That can't be possible to get a riskless portfolio that earns either more or
less than the riskless rate.
Because if,
if that did happen,
I would have,
I would have a riskless opportunity,
uh,
ability to earn more than the riskless rate with no risk.
And that that's contrary to our,
uh,
arbitrage.
So,
uh,
the return on since you,
you invested hs minus c in the portfolio,
the return on the total value of it has to equal one plus the riskless rate
times hs minus C a.
And if you substitute in for Ahs minus C,
you find out that it equals this,
uh,
and a substitute for h into this and you'll get the price of the call today.
It's simple Algebra,
but there it is.
So that's the arbitrage theory call option price.
Uh,
that might be less than intuitive to you,
but you see that it was very simple arguing that got us there.
We merely said the way to think about options is that options move with the
stock price.
Um,
and,
uh,
they're,
they're perfectly correlated with the stock price over this interval because if
the stock price goes up,
you know,
you've got seats of a,
of view as the stock price goes down,
you know,
you've got [inaudible] so you have only one source of uncertainty,
but you have to assets so you can put them together to eliminate risk.
And if you put them together that way,
they have to earn the riskless rate and you just solve for and you get this
value for the call option.
This is the inherent insight that black and shoals,
uh,
came up with in there.
A classic 1973 paper on option pricing,
which I'll come to,
but
this has to be the price of the call option in this simple world.
Uh,
otherwise there'd be arbitrage.
The interesting thing about this is that there are no probabilities in this
formula.
What's in this formula?
I've got the riskless rate,
I've got intrinsic value.
I've got the,
the difference between the price and the two circumstances,
but nothing to do with probabilities.
And this puzzled people,
people thought,
well,
doesn't the price of an option have to depend on the probability that it will
come in the money?
If it's an out of the money option?
Don't I weigh the probability?
But it's not in this formula.
Uh,
you might say it's implicitly in the formula because the relationship of ass to
Su and SD involves probabilities,
but it's not in this formula.
So black and shoals in their famous paper use this kind of reasoning to get to
the,
the standard option contract,
which,
uh,
option formula and uh,
I'm not going to derive it because it,
the mathematics is quite a bit more difficult,
but it's exactly the same logic that I just went through with the binomial
option pricing formula.
Uh,
and so this is one of the most famous,
um,
uh,
formulas in all of finance,
what black and shows that is under a certain assumptions
about the stochastic properties of stock prices.
And under the assumption of no arbitrage opportunity,
they came up with a formula that an option price should follow,
uh,
if,
if there's no arbitrage.
So,
uh,
I'm just going to present their formula and then we'll think more about options.
But,
um,
now the black shoals formula called t,
the time to exercise,
uh,
before I just said it was when we talked binomial,
I just had,
um,
I said it was one period,
hence,
but now we're allowing the exercise date to be any distance in the future.
Uh,
so t is the time to,
uh,
to the exercise date.
And this is a for a European option,
although it's often used to apply to American options as well,
and we'll call a sigma squared the variance of the one period price change.
Okay.
Uh,
and,
and of acts is the cumulative normal distribution function,
uh,
which you can find on excel.
It's,
it's called norm dist.
Uh,
but,
uh,
and so,
I don't want to get into these detailed,
this is the formula that black and fuels,
uh,
won the Nobel Prize for actually black,
black,
uh,
died at a
relatively early age from throat cancer.
Uh,
he was a heavy smoker and people don't do that anymore.
So I was one risk,
uh,
is over.
But,
um,
uh,
shoals won the Nobel prize for this.
They don't award that posthumously for this little formula.
It says the price of a call a is equal to the stock price times and of d one
minus the exercise price times and have d two l where d one is given by this
expression and d two is given by this expression.
So,
um,
uh,
that might not be intuitive to you.
We could spend a couple of lectures making that more intuitive,
but I'm just going to stop with that formula now.
But that's the formula that I used back here to make this pink line.
I just,
I had to plug in a value for sigma squared and t uh,
yeah,
but I did that and I used the black show formula.
So the black Sholes formula does what we sort of think it should be.
The price of an option should be greater than the intrinsic value of it
everywhere.
Um,
but,
uh,
it's,
but here's the exact equation.
MMM.
So this is one of the most famous equations and fine,
it might even be on your,
if you have a financial calculator,
you might have a key that you can press a,
it's already on your laptop so you don't even know.
It probably maybe if anyone,
what kind of programs you have.
Uh,
but it's easy to compute an excel.
You just have to use this norm.
Dist uh,
this cumulative normal distribution function is not something you can do by
hand.
You have to use,
uh,
cause it wouldn't involve a,
an integral that that doesn't have an analytic solution but a,
you can get it on an excel.
Uh,
so,
um,
now,
uh,
the,
the critical problem with the black Sholes formula however,
is getting some of these parameters that have to go into it.
And the tough one is sigma squared.
Most of the other things we know if you're trying to actually price an option
using black Sholes as we already know,
that that's just the stock price.
He is the exercise price.
We know that that's,
that's written in the option contract.
T is the time to expiration date.
We know that that's written in the contract are,
is the riskless interest rate.
Well,
that's easy to tell.
That's just quoted in the market.
There's only one thing that remains,
that's tough.
And that's sigma squared.
That's the variance of the stock price.
Uh Huh.
Black Sholes says you have to know how variable the stock price is to price an
option.
Uh,
and intuitively,
uh,
you,
you can see it.
Isn't it obvious that the,
the more variable the stock price,
the more valuable the option is,
right?
If the,
if the variance were zero,
then the option would just be the intrinsic value,
right?
Uh,
because there's no chance for the stock to do anything unexpected.
So if it's out of the money and,
and very into zero,
the option is worthless.
If it's in the money and the variance is zero,
then it's worth something,
but it's only worth the intrinsic value.
If sigma squared is zero,
the price can't move anywhere.
So there's no problem.
Uh,
as sigma squared increases,
the option gets more and more valuable.
If it's out of the money.
It's getting more and more chance to come into the money.
Uh,
and so that's in the formula.
So the key in the black Sholes formula is the variance of,
of,
um,
of option of the underlying stock price.
Uh,
and that's the,
that's the kicker.
That's the hard part.
People who trade options use the black Sholes formula,
but there's a problem.
And the problem is you've got to plug in a number for a sigma squared.
So what number should I plug in?
Well,
you might say,
let's take historical numbers.
All right.
Uh,
I know pretty much what the variance of stock price changes is.
Let's use the historical variants.
So I wanted to show you the historical variants of stock price.
I haven't since I like history,
I go all the way back to 1871.
So what I did to compute this chart is I took the s and p composite or s and p
500 index back to 1871.
This is my spreadsheet,
which is on the web,
uh,
on under our classroom materials.
Uh,
and I took a six month moving average of six months changes.
well,
six months standard deviation of the percentage price change for every month
from 1871 July to April of 2008.
Uh,
and the,
the important thing to understand here is that the variance is not constant
through time.
It moves around.
There are high variance periods for stock prices and low variance periods.
I like to look at this picture cause it's interesting.
The first thing that is interesting is that overall the market has been
remarkably consistent for over a hundred years,
right?
The variants back in the 19th century,
it doesn't look any different.
Nothing has changed in 130 years.
The market has always been volatile.
There's only one thing that jumps out at you when you look at this picture.
And that's these numbers in here,
right?
You notice those numbers in the middle.
That was the Great Depression of the 1930s.
Uh,
and uh,
something went really haywire in the financial markets and the depression.
This is 1929.
It wasn't so much 19,
29,
but remember this is a six month.
It's a lagging six months.
So where does it,
maybe the 1929 crash is here or somewhere
and not sure exactly where it is,
but
something went really haywire after 1929 and the market's got extraordinarily
volatile for awhile.
Uh,
that was a crisis period in American history.
That's shows up really well on this picture.
But since then,
nothing much has happened.
Uh,
it's,
it isn't.
Look recently,
this doesn't look very important.
It shows how important our lifetimes are in the broad sweep of history.
But,
uh,
your lifetimes are from uh,
or in this region right here.
Right.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the thing that's interesting is that we have been recently in a very low
volatility period for the stock market.
This is around 2003.
We were in a high volatility period in 19 nine.
He's nothing like in the Great Depression,
but tie in the 90s and then volatility just collapsed in the markets where the
dentist and Dallas place to be in the world stock market.
Um,
and uh,
partly I think this is because our,
we were,
who knows where this was.
I'm going to throw out wild suggestion.
It's because we were distracted by the housing bubble and all talk after the
stock market peak in 2000 lots of people just lost interest in the market and
all of their speculative enthusiasm was focused on housing and the stock market
was kind of forgotten.
There has to be at least an element of truth to that story.
But something has been happening lately,
like how much volatility is shooting up now?
This is because of the world financial crisis that we're in.
But if you look at this picture,
it doesn't look like the world.
Financial crisis is very important,
uh,
in compared to historical events so far,
that we've seen in the past.
Now I want to define what we call implied volatility.
Uh,
what,
what the you can do with the black Sholes formula is it requires that you input
sigma squared to calculate what the price of an option should be.
Well,
why don't we take what the price of the option is and work backwards to figure
out what volatility is implied by the price.
You see what I'm saying?
You can solve,
you can turn the black schole,
the black Sholes formula.
It gives the price of the option in terms of sigma squared.
Well I can turn it around cause I know what the market price of the option is.
They're traded on the CVOE.
Uh,
so I would take the market price of an option and turn it around and get what
the implied volatility is from black shoals and,
uh,
the,
the CBO,
he does this for you because they trade s and p 500 options and they have it on
their website.
Uh,
and it's called Vic's.
I have there,
that's their volatility index.
Uh,
and the CBO [inaudible] was created in 1973.
unfortunately their series,
it doesn't,
it goes only back to 1986.
Um,
but it's been going for a long time.
You can't get implied volatility back to 1871,
because although there were options traded back down,
there was no organized market.
You can't get a consistent series of prices of options going that far back.
So you can't get implied volatility.
Maybe you could do it if you got some records from some broker and find some
options.
But I it would,
I don't know,
it would be hard.
So our,
our,
um,
imply volatility only goes back a
little over 20 years.
But the interesting thing is I have plotted here both the implied volatility
over that period and the actual volatility and you see that they line up fairly
well.
So this shows the strength of the black Sholes formula.
Black Sholes does seem to be pricing options,
uh,
well enough because the implied volatility,
well,
it's not perfectly exactly equal to the actual volatility.
It's close.
And so,
uh,
we can see that the formula make some,
some sense.
Uh,
I think,
yeah.
So I just wanted to
conclude this lecture by,
um,
talking about,
the,
uh,
effort we've made to get a single family home price options going,
at the Chicago Mercantile Exchange.
So,
uh,
as I told you,
I am,
some of my colleagues have been campaigning with futures exchanges to create
futures markets for home prices and ultimately for commercial real estate prices
and other economic variables.
Uh,
so we went to,
uh,
w w w we,
we started campaigning almost 20 years ago,
but recently we have been talking with the Chicago Mercantile Exchange and they
created futures markets for single family homes in,
uh,
may of 2006 using the s and p case Shiller indexes.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so,
that,
that was their objective.
But when we went there,
the CME said,
well,
why don't we start options as well,
options on futures.
Uh,
so we have a futures contract and they launched options on home prices.
and you can see all these things on the Chicago Mercantile Exchange website.
Uh,
and,
uh,
what we have now are both puts and calls for 10 US cities.
Uh,
unfortunately they are not doing well and not selling well,
but,
uh,
we're,
we're there.
They're still going.
And,
um,
we're hoping that we can,
uh,
get them to connect the often markets go slow at first.
Uh,
so I hope that that's the story,
that it's just a slow beginning,
but let me say what we have and maybe it's a good down to earth way to
illustrate the value of options.
I was telling you how to price options,
but I didn't tell you why would you buy one?
Well,
I did tell a story at the beginning.
I talked about an investor wanting to invest money in options,
uh,
and a writer,
hoping that the option will expire on exercise and hoping to make money.
But I didn't really go behind that and,
and emphasize why you would do that.
So I think the example of a home price options is very,
uh,
easy to see.
Uh,
let's consider a situation that someone,
I don't think any of you are homeowners here,
right this point.
Maybe some of you are probably not.
But imagine,
try to imagine that you bought a house a couple of years ago.
Okay.
Uh,
and now the housing market is collapsing.
you know,
you bought that house probably on a mortgage,
so you borrowed 80 or 90%,
or maybe even more of the money to buy the house.
And,
uh,
now the home prices falling and you're thinking,
Hey,
wait a minute,
this house is worth less than my debt.
Uh,
and you start to get upset with,
you know,
you're thinking,
well,
you know,
I'd like to move to another city,
but then you realize I can't do it.
I,
if I sell my house,
I won't be able to pay off the mortgage.
I'll be bankrupt,
uh,
before I,
I can't move.
And this is very real.
In fact,
a economy.com,
a consulting firm estimates that in the United States today,
10% of all homes are underwater.
In that sense,
the mortgage debt is greater than the value of the home,
and that number is increasing every day as home prices continue to fall.
So some people are very upset.
Uh,
so what can they do?
Well,
one thing they can do,
or they could have done a couple of years ago,
if they,
if,
if they had a thought to do it,
they could buy a put on the home on homes in the city where they have a house,
right?
So I hope I put in,
say around,
let's say I put in $500,000 into a house and um,
I'm worried that it's price might fall.
Well,
if you buy a house and you buy a put on that house together,
the two together,
uh,
eliminate your risk.
So if I this,
think of it as just buying a put on a house rather than an index.
I buy the house for 500,000.
I put up 400,000 and so I'm,
I put 100,000 and the mortgage puts up 400,000.
I'm underwater if the house drops $100,000.
Right?
I've lost my mortgage.
Debt exceeds my,
I don't want that to happen.
So why don't I just buy a put on the house,
which is a right to sell the house at $400,000,
uh,
until some exercise date,
right then I can't possibly be underwater if I ever decide to move.
If it's an American option,
I can just actually,
if the price of my house is less than 400,000,
I just actually saw my put,
there's no way for me to get wiped out.
In fact,
I could buy a put at 450,000.
Uh,
and that way I would always be sure that I have $50,000 left.
So that's the idea of using option as a hedging mechanism.
And uh,
uh,
well I gave an example in terms of real estate and it's not why they use that
way.
This same idea is used a lot by investors in other domains.
So I think options have a very real risk management of purpose.
Um,
and so,
you know,
in a sense an insurance contract is like a put option.
If I buy fire insurance on my house,
then,
uh,
it's like buying a put option on my house.
But it's only exercisable if there's a fire.
So what it says is if my house burns down the put option,
I can sell the whatever remains,
uh,
at a,
at a price,
which is determined by the insurance contract.
It's the same as a put option.
So insurance is not fundamentally different from finance.
And so we'd had a little trouble deciding whether we want home equity insurance
or just puts a home equity put.
So we've created the,
puts a,
at some point we want to also create,
uh,
insurance,
on homes someday.
I hope that happens.
Uh,
there is no home equity insurance,
but um,
but these are just different incarnations of the same risk management ideas.
The fundamental idea here in finance is that you can create the options are
example of derivatives.
I should add that um,
a derivative is a financial contract that derives from another financial.
So an option is a derivative because the price of the option in the options
market depends on the price of something else in another market,
the stock market.
And so our real estate options are another example of derivative.
The price of the put option depends on,
in the option market,
depends on the price of the house in the housing market.
Uh,
so one of the themes in my forthcoming book,
which I'm writing right now,
is that derivatives are like insurance.
They're fundamentally important risk management vehicles,
and they could have helped prevent the subprime crisis that we're now in if they
had just gotten more established and more developed.